foreign
no
for this particular agenda point I would
like to welcome the commission
is
so first of all commission statement
on Rising precariousness in Europe and
the need for Aid
for the most deprived
within the European Union and I'd like
to invite our first Speaker Mr Nicolas
Schmidt commissioner you have the floor
thank you very much
presidents
first I would like to thank the
parliament for scheduling this timely
debate indeed it is important to start
this session with a debate on a crucial
problem
millions of citizens are daily
confronted with
the overall economic prospects are
challenging following the impact of the
covet pandemic the energy crisis and
finally
the inflation hikes in general terms
indicators on risks of poverty and
social exclusion have remained overall
stable
over the past few years
but as so often statistics do not tell
the whole story
inflation hits
particularly vulnerable households
and lower medium income
families
indeed it is also true that income
support measures put in place have
mitigated the impact of high energy
prices and inflation
and therefore we can acknowledge
some positive impact of the exceptional
and temporary measures adopted both at
EU and member states level
but poverty remains acute in Europe and
citizens are quite rightly concerned
to have a serious impact
more structural measures are needed to
address poverty
and precarious living and working
conditions
in work poverty is also a persisting
challenge in the EU especially for
people in non-standard forms of
employment
among them many young people and many
women
and for non-eu citizens
under the portal declaration EU leaders
committed to reducing inequalities and
ensuring Fair wages fighting social
exclusion and tackling poverty taking on
in particular the objective of fighting
child poverty
where we observe encouraging data and
employment
we register little progress towards the
goal of poverty reduction and social
inclusion
the social and economic effects of the
covet pandemic the war in Ukraine and
subsequent cost of living crisis have
Amplified existing social inequalities
a rising number of families across
Europe have begun to fall into food
poverty and are increasingly reliant on
food banks and similar services to meet
basic needs and here
I underline the importance of the Fiat
program
which can help or at least contribute to
lower the needs of these families of
these people
and I
appeal to member states to use the money
the remaining money which is in Fair
still
available
to use it to alleviate these needs
the effects of the cost of living
including the cost of housing are felt
unevenly across Society lower income
groups and vulnerable citizens have been
most affected of course
it is the moment to step up our efforts
towards achieving our Target of reducing
by 2030 the number of persons at risk of
poverty or social exclusion in the EU by
at least 15 million of which at least
five million should be children
we must live up to our commitments
strong and efficient welfare systems
adequate provision and take up of Social
Services are necessary to fight poverty
and ensure social cohesion you must
address the root causes of poverty break
the cycle of disadvantage and address
the new challenges
and this context it is critical that
governments assess the distributional
effects of their policies Investments
and reforms on the most vulnerable
tackling poverty and social exclusion is
at the center of the European pillar of
social rights and its action plan and
the number of key steps have been taken
at the EU level
the European child guarantee which
guarantees access to key services for
children in need
member states have to allocate a certain
percentage of their ESF plus money to
its implementation which amounts to
approximate 9 billion euros
the directive on adequate minimum wages
ensuring workers can afford a decent
standard of living and here I noticed
that in many member states minimum wages
have been increased before even the
transposition of the directive
the council recommendation on an
adequate minimum income ensuring active
inclusion
in some member States minimum income has
been adjusted unfortunately not in all
and even the contrary has happened
the European platform on combating
homelessness
we will have another opportunity to
discuss the housing crisis that hits
millions of Europeans
adequate financial resources and
policies are needed at National and
European level we support and complement
member states action to the European
semester and EU funding such as fire the
fund for European Aid to the most
deprived with uh 4.6 billion earmarked
to address material deprivation the
European social fund plus with an
investment in support to social
inclusion of 45.5 billion and 5.5
billion for material support to the most
deprived for the period 2127 and under
the recovery and resilience facility 28
have been allocated to social
Investments
to effectively tackle the root causes of
poverty social policies must go hand in
hand with economic and fiscal policies
as well as more inclusive and Fair Labor
markets aiming at Upward social and
economic conversions it I also want to
mention repower EU that can contribute
to combat energy poverty as well as the
EU social climate fund that should
compensate those families most impacted
by price increases
so many actions have been put into into
place
at EU level as well as on member states
level but the situation remains
extremely worrisome
therefore we cannot take our food of the
accelerator
obviously we have to combat more
effectively
unjustified price increases that fuel
inflation
it and at the same time vulnerable
households need further support even if
this support has been has to be more
targeted
precariousness poverty and social
exclusion should have no place in our
European Union therefore combating them
should be our common priority thank you
thank you very much
for your introduction remarks your
comments
now we come to come to speaker
Madam Cindy Francis
thank you very much president
commissioner colleagues poverty and
social exclusion
affect 95 million European citizens and
25 million of those are children the
costs of living have risen exponentially
energy costs are extremely high rent is
through the roof and many people simply
can't afford a home over their heads and
they simply can't make ends meet this is
becoming an increasing problem more and
more people are resorting to food banks
more and more people are in need of the
support and there's less and less
available inflation is about 30 percent
in some areas and financial support from
ESF plus is simply woefully inaccurate
inadequate we need to increase the
finance we have available in these
programs because people are in such
desperate need the lights are all flash
red extremely red and it's our moral
duty to accept to be protecting and
helping the most vulnerable people much
more is necessary we need to have a much
greater measure of ambition we talked
about removing people from poverty
in huge numbers in the context of the
sdgs for example but we have simply
failed to do this so the our next
legislature has got to have much more
stringent targets and has got to achieve
them we can't simply keep putting on the
back burner that this issue of tackling
poverty and social exclusion so much
more has got to be done in terms of
social policy and supporting our
citizens who are in darn it thank you
thank you very much the floor
thank you Mr President dear commissioner
Nicole Schmidt colleagues
decommissioner in the State of the Union
president from the line failed to
address the struggle of European
families no red heart no social
commitment at that moment from her
and we do are still so far from the port
of social objectives namely on poverty
and that is why debt silence was so
concerning I am glad that you brought
energy and that you broke that silence
today in the name of the commission
because the war triggered the cost of
living crisis many families as it was
just said they cannot even make ends
meet even if they are fully employed
housing costs are skyrocketing for those
families in particular for the
youngsters anyone that loses their job
at this stage or even anyone who chooses
to divorce they face enormous risks at
this stage for women as always the risks
are even more acute the you must deliver
on the Porto agenda with more ESF more
rrf funds to the most excluding putting
pressure from the commission to the
member states to priorize social housing
on their recovery plans like a
progressive government did in Portugal
finding the resources for the child
guarantee filed nearly finding the
resources for the child guarantee from
the commission for the poverty goal
thank you
thank you in all of our member states
and in my country France associations
are overwhelmed there are fewer
donations and yet demand is on the
increase and winter is coming and yet we
live in one of the richest regions of
the world millions of our fellow
citizens are currently fighting for
their survival they can't get a hot meal
they can't get health care there's the
war in Ukraine the energy crisis also
food prices have skyrocketed all of this
makes it very difficult to make ends
meet we can't be a union of values if we
allow this Injustice to continue
we need to reduce poverty that's what we
said at the Porto Summit commissioner
that is the right target commission and
Council need to step up the pace now we
need to act as Europeans in order to get
tangible results
we need to make sure that we use the
funds that are available to us and we
need to feed them and of course we need
to fight all forms of poverty especially
extreme poverty a new Summit would be
required there won't be a reduction in
poverty if we don't have measures to
counter Galloping inflation we need to
deal with debt
ecological issues we know that there are
solutions out there we also know it's
not easy but I would like to pay tribute
to silvi pruni my colleague who can't be
here but a Europe based on social values
or solidarity that is the cause that we
should all be fighting for thank you
merci miss you
thank you Mr munir satri thank you very
much president colleagues
thank you commissioner Schmidt
statistics can never give us the real
picture the full picture of all the
suffering and the terrible situation of
mounting difficulties which many of our
citizens are funny finding they are
facing on a daily basis and therefore we
need to have a coherent strategy
vis-a-vis the member states I'm sorry
that Mr seizureone is not here because
it was renewed that proposed we have
this item on the agenda and I would have
liked to congratulate him on his sense
of timing because this is a debate which
taking place at a time when
and his presidential
majority of course renew represents that
are actually facing difficulties in
trying to force more people to go to
work for 15 hours a week in order to get
a minimum
wage which is way be the poverty level
so we need to have a coherent policy and
we need to take some action we're told
for example that 35 of the population
can't even eat three meals a day and
there are far too many who are facing
huge problems in accessing any kind of
support there are many many difficulties
in providing for the amount of support
for food banks which is necessary and
we've really got to mobilize and this is
why Europe has got to
mobilize all the resources it has to
good end for example we have got the
good fortune of having some
payments which can be made available
under European policy but we can't be
substituting solidarity with Charity
because we've got to remember human
dignity is of the essence it's
absolutely Paramount here and therefore
it's a question of looking at how we can
deal with food security how we can
provide better support for food
distribution and food assistance after
all winter is around the corner and the
situation will only deteriorate still
further thank you Elizabeth
you are the next one
foreign commissioner
ladies and gentlemen
in Europe the crisis
one crisis seems to be leading to
another
and
of course it is those most in need the
most deprived who suffer greatest under
these circumstances
73 million Europeans are threatened by
poverty
one in four children
39 of children
in
mid income and low-income families are
suffering in my country in Poland
a country which has been unjustly
attacked repeatedly in this chamber we
have a totally different situation we
have Security on the labor market we
have support for those unemployed we
have less poverty
one of the most important indices
all those indices that tell us about for
example child poverty
education level and so on and so forth
those indices are all much higher in
Poland
uh policies for people in difficult
situations for those who have been
deprived because of different conditions
either because their children or older
people they are protected by the Polish
state we have a robust State system
which supports these individuals so
perhaps you ought to look at the example
that we have to provide
our next speaker is
Conte
thank you the recent energy crisis and
escalating inflation have had a very
adverse impact on our families
throughout Europe not just the most
vulnerable
at one family in three is struggling to
make ends meet and in Italy this figure
is a mountain is approximately
approximates to one in two this is a
terrible Scourge across our society and
more and more people are feeling
marginalized marginalized and excluded
especially people who have short time or
seasonal contracts zero hours contracts
working in agriculture fishering tourism
and building these people have only got
part-time work they're working in
certain Seasons when needed and
therefore they're living in a terribly
ins unstable situation they don't know
where they'll get their next job from
and therefore they are resorting to
having to take on loans the situation
for people marginalized in this way and
on the periphery of society is ever
worse they're getting no protection and
so we need to protect their rights
protect their work and ensure that they
get this support that they need thank
you thank you miss you mark podenga
thank you very much potenka please you
have the floor
thank you very much president
commissioner
I think really
you're not seeing the wood for the trees
we have a social emergency today in
Europe it's awful in Belgium a quarter
of parents can't actually feed their
children properly three-quarters of
teachers have already
seen children who are starving at school
students can't find student residences
housing and if today as a worker you
want to take public transport well you
know delays
trains that are canceled and don't fall
ill whatever you do because hospitals
are understaffed and they don't have the
equipment they need if you happen to be
reaching retirement age well your legal
pension will probably probably not be
sufficient to guarantee or to cover what
you need for instance for a home but
what you're also not talking about is
the consequences of European policy here
liberalization austerity which you
imposed and the worst and let's be
honest here when it comes to workers
workers are facing such a hard time what
the commission is suggesting is coming
back with the budgetary pact with cuts
into public services that's the worst
and that's absolutely unacceptable we're
going to fight it
thank you our next speaker is Mr nicolao
alavanos
is
statements made by the Austrian
Chancellor basically implying if they
have no bread let them eat cake this
displays the deeply anti-popular
anti-social strategy of minimum rights
espoused by Bourgeois governments in the
EU making Cuts in benefits to support
the poor increase poverty coupons were
only given to the victims of flood
problems continue
There is that cycle of
profit we have the
work day being undermined now 13 hours
in Greece subsidies and support for
Consortium pushing for green and digital
transition this is boosted inflation we
have energy poverty interest with raised
hikes all resulting in households in
need losing their very homes in the end
so yesterday it was called they were
called vulnerable now they're called
deprived
but there's not been no change in
strategy precariousness still exists
housing issues poverty and really only
if these classes organize will they be
able to overcome this Scourge most of
law is yours
million
those are the numbers in
the European Union the number of people
that are threatened by poverty in 2022
by social exclusion one in four citizens
of the European Union is under threat
but
the Terrible
issue is that this particular figure has
not dropped over the last couple of
years it has remained the same
this is undermines social cohesion and
it also May undermine the European
experiment the European construct that
we have that we all support we need to
provide support to those that are in
need and that's why I'm glad that
governments like the government of
kiriakos mitsotikis are doing just that
the government of Mr Constantino's has
increased the minimum wage
adopted specific targeted measures to
support the deprived there's also the
racial component as well and the gender
component women and young people are
under greater threat
so we have to boost small and
middle-sized Enterprises the very
pillars of our economies we have to
provide for them as well and we need to
make something that will create and then
reacting to create an environment
basically that will support
these types of Enterprises support jobs
creation of jobs and maintenance of jobs
sustainable jobs and for all of this we
have to be certain that the member
states will implement
the legislative measures that have been
adopted the new legislation that's out
there right now to provide the those
living in precarious situations those
that are deprived
we need a true European social Union
which provides for all and which
provides for social cohesion that is the
road that we have to follow that is the
trajectory that will lead to European
cohesion and Unity thank you
Madam
excuse me excuse me
I have one of one colleague before
Madame Agnes jungarians
thank you very much
more and more people are falling between
the falling through the net they can't
pay their bills they're having to resort
to food banks and they're facing huge
problems they have absolutely no way
they can replace their washing machine
for example if it breaks down and that
even people who are working full time so
it is high time that we actually
implemented the minimum wage directive
everybody's entitled to a minimum wage
on which they can live and which takes
into account inflation levels but we
need much more we need adequate minimum
wages yes we need legislation on that
but the reality is when half of your
income is going to go at least on
actually paying for your house and
affording any heating for that house
then you have a serious problem and this
is a case not only in Amsterdam or in
Utrecht it's the case everywhere so many
people can't afford a house in the first
place and if they even have one they
can't afford to heat it and winter is
around the corner so what does the
commission intend to do to make life
more affordable thank you
thank you very much the next speakers
Fabian Keller
Mr President
dear
Ottmar Karas commissioner
dear Nicholas Schmidt dear colleagues
you've already said it
around Europe as a whole of most
vulnerable fellow citizens are in
difficulty associations who help the
most deprived in France I'm thinking of
food banks I'm thinking of the
restaurant
they're calling out the fact that
there's an increasing number of people
who depend on them they're also saying
how difficult it is for them to keep
Services going because of
price Rises that's true for for instance
the premises where they host the most
vulnerable heating costs and it's also
of course a consequence of covid as you
said commissioner the budget of the
European Union has a Target namely four
percent of the European social fund
resources should be set aside for food
Aid and basic health for the most
deprived shouldn't we perhaps update
that Target make it a bit more ambitious
in order to help the really most
vulnerable and how can we incentivize
member states to do more to be more
ambitious you talked about the fact that
we should use our funds in order to help
the most deprived
I know of course because I'm reporter
for the budget that the margins are
tight but commissioner solidarity has to
be a priority for us all thank you may I
see
thank you very much
the next speaker is Sarah Matthew
said thank you very much indeed
president commissioner you have made a
statement on increasing poverty in
Europe and frankly we needed this a long
time ago it's not one minute too soon in
her State of the Union Address
unfortunately president Funderland
didn't even devote a millisecond to this
and that despite the percentage of
people living in poverty in Europe the
number of people who are homeless and
the burgeoning Specter of poverty which
is causing uncertainty and fear
throughout Europe so tackling poverty is
actually the top priority for our
citizens that's what they need us to do
if you look at the Europe barometer
publication anyway not so long ago the
your European social pillar was adopted
but frankly this Parliament is always
arguing the case that we need to do more
to bring people out of poverty and right
now we are more than ever in dire need
of these proposals to help people to
escape from poverty what about the
in-work poor well there are even more of
those there is no transition from
in work poverty to in work keeping your
head above the parapet it's just not
possible anymore and we need some proper
social policy thank you
thank you very much indeed the
purchasing power of every European is
under pressure the recent Europe
Armature Studies have shown that more
than half of Europeans feel that their
purchasing power has declined
considerably over the past three years
now that's actually a very shockingly
high percentage so this fall in
purchasing part is clearly due to the
escalating inflation
but it is also due to more than that
it's not just the war in Ukraine it it's
not just due to covet and it's not just
to to those who have been benefiting
from that it's also due to the lack of
energy transition and that's partly why
our Energy prices are escalating and
it's all very well to talk about
security of existence but we're going to
have to do something to make people's
lives less insecure and that means we're
going to have to make it less
bureaucratic we're going to have to
address the issues that we have we're
going to have to tackle inflation and
we're going to have to try to do
something rapidly to make sure that our
taxpayers can actually make ends meet at
last thank you
our next speaker is Madame Dominique
Builder this is
thank you president commissioner
the European Union is asking French
citizens to welcome everyone from around
the world or the poor or the deprived
and yet in Brussels technocrats
disconnected from
reality
are failing to see how hard times are
for our citizens our systems are at the
end of their tether we don't have money
you're saying give money to migrants
French people can't actually Heat their
homes we're providing Health Care to
foreigners a majority of our own
Nationals aren't going to the doctor
because they don't have the means you're
also talking about regularizing illegal
migrants
and at the same time preventing our
Nationals from living in their own
country I think we should defend our own
before we defend others it's a very
simple solution
after all that is what is logical and
that is what we should be doing at long
lasting
is our next speaker is
president thank you very much
in our criminal code there is a crime a
failing to assist people in danger and
this is based on a moral and ethical
right people should be protected but
there is no such right in European law
and yet it is so important at the moment
half of our
population is living in a situation of
some kind of deprivation
all too many of them can't switch on
their heating they can't make ends meet
on a monthly basis they can't eat in the
way that they should some of them can't
eat at all and after all we are one of
the Prime economies in the global market
therefore we need to act as rapidly as
possible in order to support the
vulnerable in order to support the
associations which are helping
vulnerable and deprived communities to
do something about the energy tariffs at
home for homes and we've also got to do
something about abandoning austerity
introducing windfall taxes and making
sure that all the other numerous
solutions that we could Implement are
finally actually seeing the light of day
thank you
Mr Adam kosher please you have the floor
please
we have a responsibility to make sure
that as many of our citizens as possible
feel safe and secure the key to that is
decent work if you have work you have
everything in Hungary in 2010 we decided
not to go for benefits but rather to
create a society focused on jobs
and in Hungary we therefore have a
work-based economy thanks to that in
July 2023 our unemployment rate in
Hungary was only 3.9 compare that to the
EU where the average was 5.9 and if you
take just the Eurozone it's 6.4 percent
now the left always argues that the
solution lies in benefits such as the
universal minimum wage or income that's
wrong-headed I actually think that if
you want to reduce poverty you need to
create jobs that is the answer
in Hungary we have a program
for public works and thanks to that we
have been able in Hungary to really
reduce the risk of poverty and social
exclusion compared to others in the EU I
mean last year our rate of exclusion was
18.4 percent whereas in 2010 it was 30
thank you
very much president
commissioner Nicola Schmidt well the
problems have been stated
and I think it's I think it's quite
clear that the statistics don't tell the
whole story that behind the statistics
there are human beings children women uh
uh
the issue of uh
Unemployment uh lack of employment as
well has led to a situation which is
totally uh unbearable we need a
consistent strategy this situation that
exists right now undermines democracy
people have the feelings that they
really will not be able to manage
because prices are increases increasing
so this week there was an article of
Adam in the financial times uh referring
to the situation in Germany as well but
it's clear it also concerns the entire
EU the uh extreme right uh the growth of
the extreme right as well the lack of
housing the numerous different problems
and of course if we at the same time if
we speak about foreigners being the
cause of the problem indeed we're not
focusing on the real core of the issue
and we will not be able to resolve the
issues thank you Marius
colleague photos
thank you chairman
commissioner colleagues in the past four
years we've seen major challenges and
crisis that we've never seen before in
the EU Health Care crisis the inflation
the energy crisis and of course the war
in Ukraine
all these changes have impacted our
economy and have impacted European
citizens who see their revenue dwindling
less job opportunities and higher and
higher prices we all voted for the
recovery and resilience facility which
should have been felt by every citizen
should have benefited every citizen but
this isn't happening yet
more citizens are
living in precarious conditions and many
member states are unable to implement
the projects and the reforms as they
should
it is high time we invest in the
European economy because only a strong
economy can help us increase welfare for
our European citizens and can help us
increase our security as a union
yes Mr
Michael
he's okay okay
um
are you you're from a liberal party and
I'd like to find out
speaker has been interrupted oh
I do you have interpretation appears not
oh it's working
okay please okay okay
as I was saying
are you from uh you're from a liberal
party which has enormous influence here
in the European Union in June of this
year in Brussels
a think tank generated an article
written by a professor who said that
the policies of the European Union are
extremely expensive the particularly the
energy policies and that creates a very
difficult situation for the deprived in
society don't you see this as a problem
that don't you see this as an issue that
in other words that the energy policy of
the European Union has a terrible has
terrible consequences for the man on the
street in Europe
Yes dear conservative colleague I know
you are currently in
campaign in your country and you've
chosen me as a Target but I think I am
the wrong person to be targeted yes I am
part of the renew Europe group but maybe
you are not aware of my convictions and
you have not followed my votes
okay you were in the middle of your
election campaign but maybe you
shouldn't be using the hemicycle to do
it
thank you commissioner president
colleagues
tackling poverty isn't a new challenge
people in the European Union
have been dealing with this for a long
time but what is poverty poverty is not
being able to eat healthily not being
able to buy any school books certainly
not being able to go to the theater and
these are all things which you should be
able to do if you have a stake in
society we have established a social
Fund in the European Union but it's
woefully under-resourced we have a child
guarantee scheme but unfortunately it
hasn't been implemented in any member
states yet so for goodness sake the
European Union has got to give itself a
reality check we should actually have
some basic insurance it's not
something which we can afford to
aspire to it's something that we've got
to achieve we have got to ensure that
the commission that comes into force
with the new into into Power with the
new Parliament actually recognizes that
forward-looking thinking is finally
something that they have to deliver we
can't just have this kind of Peace
giving people a few crumbs for the table
when they're in poverty we've got to do
something constructive to help people
out of what is structural poverty rather
than simply perpetuating it thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
um
president ladies
lady the problem of poverty in the
European Union is a particularly
important one I'm of the impression that
the groups here representing the left
that they are to focus on issues
which involve real concerns but what's
happening with the left and the far left
is that they are not taking
responsibility for the consequences of
their particular policies so we have a
very restrictive climate policy which
has been adopted which has led to energy
poverty in the European Union I don't
know if you're aware of this fact
that in other words
these are these are the problems this is
what the core of the issue is
um if you
with the law and Justice government in
Poland
we've had in 148 increase in the minimum
wage and the poverty level in Poland is
one of the lowest in the European Union
we have a great development and things
are moving forward in Poland on that
front thank you
uh thank you president colleagues
commissioner thank you very much for
calling me to the floor I'm not going to
repeat what previous speakers have said
already on the European labor market the
most vulnerable the most poor are the
Roma in Hungary we have been able to
improve employment rates for the Roma
community
there's discrimination in the workplace
of course there's lack of vocational
training in addition to which
compared to their qualifications these
poorest people get the worst jobs now a
member of the Roma Community who is poor
may be able to cope with all of these
challenges but still they have to face
all sorts of other problems black work
the gig economy so short-term precarious
work poor working conditions and in the
long run for instance if you're working
on the black market it means that you
are deprived of your pension at the end
of your career look at what's been
happening to those people who have been
cleaning our streets over the last four
decades building our Nations over the
last four decades look at what happens
to them at the end of their career now
in the Hungarian presidency of 2011 we
adopted a Roma strategy and initiatives
were taken in order to try to provide
more jobs to members of the Roma
Community but it's important for the
commissioner not to do the opposite
please don't take the funds away from
these poorest people we need to make
sure that we have equal proportion and
equality and fairness from all for all
member states thank you very much
thank you very much
commissioner ladies and gentlemen
precarious work means precarious life
we should not permit that non-standard
forms of employment becomes a new normal
new non-standard forms of employment are
insecure they're poorly paid they do not
provide Social Security or working
conditions
and uh precarious precariousness is
caused by succession of Crisis for
management of risks and also the fiscal
rules following the pandemic and young
and low women are especially affected
increasing Aid to the most deprived from
the European found is the least we can
do we need to address the consequences
and the causes of precarious work
together I therefore again call for the
creation of quality jobs and for the
rigorous implementation of Labor rights
for all workers fighting precarious work
also means fighting its effects on
mental health so we need a European
directive on a minimum income that
enables decent living we also need a
European unemployment insurance scheme
and a European care guarantee thank you
my next speaker is is Mr Max Orville
commissioner president colleagues
our social model is a promise which we
make to All European unions in 2023 it
is absolutely wrong that we should be
seeing worse exclusion at people living
in a more precarious way than they were
people shouldn't be suffering from
hunger and thirst or living in shame
suffering from escalating housing and
heating costs and the impact of course
is worst on the least well off we need
to take urgent measures because the
degree of vulnerability of our
communities is increasing we need more
financial resources more support for
food distribution we need to restore the
links that there are which should bind
Society together and communities
together so that people can live
in dignity it is so important that we
ensure that we have adequate and good
social housing throughout Europe so that
people have access to quality services
of Housing and education so that we can
actually have more social inclusion and
a better mixed Society thank you the
next speaker is colleagues
one in three Europeans said that they
consider themselves to be in a financial
and material situation which is not
adequate
the Euro European barometer or the uh
statistics that have been issued this
year have shown that as well 48 of
citizens in other words almost half of
the citizens feel that they are at risk
material issues are extremely serious
the news is not good and that's why we
would like to request from the European
commission that they make more robust
solidarity mechanisms which will help
people provide Health Care Services to
those in need this has to be done at the
European Union level in Poland my group
has implemented a support policy
of where you can see very very clearly
how food has been distributed support
has been distributed as well and tax
breaks have been provided to the most
deprived in society as well
citizens are not going to be interested
in debates and hot air they need to be
able to live in dignity thank you
foreign
commissioner today in Europe 35 of
citizens find it hard to make ends meet
more than one European out of ten lives
below the breadline the figures for
vulnerability are on the increase the
economic recovery after the covert
pandemic the war in Ukraine inflation
all of them have contributed to Sky
rocketing prices to feed oneself take
care of oneself house oneself look after
your children these are vital needs but
too many European households have to
make a choice that's unacceptable
there's the working classes that are
vulnerable and increasingly also parts
of the middle classes in addition to
which the most wealthy are
proving very selfish this is threatening
our cohesion in Europe we cannot turn a
blind eye we cannot remain deaf to this
vulnerability the only European response
that is acceptable to all of these
colleagues is solidarity
thank you the next speaker is
thank you very much indeed commissioner
colleagues this week I met with some
young people from my region and we were
talking about the impact that poverty
had in accessing work and the debate
we're having here isn't really
recognizing this at all whereas and is
simply turning a blind eye to it six
million Italians who were living in
abject poverty because of escalating
record inflation are
often out of a job the European Union
has got to introduce this directive on
minimum wages and ensure that it is
enforced so that people have got access
to Services which they need many
governments are doing this slowly but
the Italian government is not at all and
this is why our workers have lost 22
percent of their purchasing power over
the last year so we therefore need an
emergency extraordinary policy to tackle
poverty we need the child guarantee yes
but we need more resources there we need
to change our budget rules so that we
can actually invest in social policy
without this adding to our deficit
social justice is Paramount it's not an
ideology it's the tissue that binds uh
healthy Society thank you thank you very
much I think the next speaker is not in
chamber therefore we have five speakers
who have requested the floor
under for catch the eye of the first
speaker is Alicia
is
thank you very much this debate allows
us to focus on real life on individuals
and the anxiety of course
of course is understandable electricity
housing and so on and so forth art
threat but there are two models that of
the right based on
Casino capitalism and the social
democracy Democratic approach which is
one based on solidarity
we want the present and future of women
children all those that are deprived to
be able to move forward
and we want to provide a
policy that will create that feeling of
robustness and provide for those that
are
that have been marginalized we want for
prosperity to be shared by All Because
Of course
Freedom cannot be negotiated and also
that sense of welfare and living in
welfare that cannot be negotiated either
thank you
the other presidents
foreign
last year
we were working
um over time in Portugal the increase in
the cost of living with prices
skyrocketing and with these minimum
wages this is what is of great concern
to people home living or housing
electricity heating workers are making
great sacrifices whereas others are
reaping major profits with this
particular situation other people are
suffering terribly education education
well there we need investment
unfortunately that isn't there right now
people don't need more statements they
don't need any more propaganda they need
support right now to be able to confront
the situation to be able to manage with
their salaries with their pensions they
need to have gas electricity energy at
an affordable price access to
telecommunication homes housing
education health care for and so forth
what's yours
price increases have made it impossible
for many people to live
many people are heroes in fact just
getting to the end of the month
commissioner you just came to Santiago
de Compostela to my con to my country my
my region you know that there we have 50
levels of precariousness there are
thousands and thousands of poor people
there's a lack of stability and the
worst thing is that we have also great
disco inequality sorry amongst young
people I mean young people who are
highly qualified they've done Advanced
Studies
but what's happening to them they're
emigrating they're emigrating to Europe
and precariousness also has a female
face it's female it's young
single-parent families are in a
situation of vulnerability these are
vulnerable classes precariousness is the
opposite of dignity
thank you
foreign
Europeans are currently living
in a precarious financial situation
this means people skipping meals when
they're hungry and not turned onto heat
when they're cold
I think it's bad in your members they
spare taught for the walkers in Ireland
Ireland is the most expensive country in
the EU for a household expenditure and
goods and services with prices 46 above
the EU average
in terms of gross Market income Ireland
is the most unequal country in the EU
Ireland's top 20 percent of earners earn
15 times more than the bottom twenty
percent according to eurostat data we
are repeatedly told by governments and
the mainstream media that pay Rises lead
to more inflation
but there's no law that says pay Rises
need to be passed on to consumers in the
form of price Rises price increases so
that profits can be maintained
prices increase so the capital increases
inflation is a function of unequal power
relations and is the very essence of
capitalism
thank you soon president they say that
you read what your soul but the reality
is when Europe's Elite Soul catastrophe
it's the people who always reap it a
recent ipsos survey revealed that a
third of Europeans are currently in a
precarious financial situation that
means they can't afford things like food
travel clothes it means they're living
in poverty or teetering on the brink of
it nearly half of Europeans say they
can't afford to heat their homes and 40
percent of parents have said they can't
meet the needs of their children one in
three skip meals so that they can feed
their kids and almost everyone is scared
everyone lives are being consumed by
anxiety sixty percent of Europeans are
worried about an unexpected expense that
could tip them over the edge now big
business was already savaging people's
lives before Europe's Powers decided
that a permanent War is better than
peace but that decision has made things
worse the people of Europe are paying
for this endless war through a cost of
living crisis what's the point in US
ringing our hands if we don't join the
dots
thank you very much indeed and it may I
now ask commissioner
Schmidt to reply to the debate
a president
well we we like to repeat
and we all agree that
nobody should be left behind
today many people more and more indeed
are left behind
and what they expect now is real
solutions
we have to be aware that these Solutions
can not only come from the European
Union
they have to be coherent as it was
repeated
coming partly from the European Union
but also from National
for member states
three observations first yes jobs are
important
without job you will not get out of
poverty
but job is not
the only way to get out of poverty
we see more than 10 percent and probably
now much more than 10 percent of working
working working poor
that's why
not precarious jobs
with a good salary
these are the jobs that bring you out of
poverty and that's why it is important
to bring more security more stability
in the job market
but also to have decent wages good Wages
that's why the directive or minimum wage
is so important to be implemented and I
would say to be implemented now
the second one is about money
what can we do I would say first let's
spend now the money which is immediately
available
there are billions
of funds in the ESF in other
funds which we have mentioned
which can be used to reduce
precariousness which can be used used to
reduce poverty inequality
let's use them that's up to the member
states to accelerate the use of this
money in that purpose
5.3 million billion just sir
for the most deprived I know that this
is not enough and will not be enough
but let's take the money now to have
those who I need
and then yes
we are in midst
of a midterm review
behind midst of a midterm review of the
mff
and Parliament if I remember well
has a word to say
please
please say it thank you
thank you for myself
well thank you very much commissioner
with that that
the debate on this particular Point
comes to an end and we come to the next
point on our agenda and I am very glad
and very grateful indeed
that all groups
uh uh have agreed that this particular
report that we're going to discuss today
will maintain the name of Madame
Veronica Noir
who a past